لقد اراد المسؤولون ان يوضحوا شيئا واحدا
فقط تلخصه عباره لم نجد الطائره بعد لكن
بعد اكثر من شهر من البحث عن الطائره
الماليزيه المفقوده حصل المسؤولون على ما
يعتبر اكثر طريق واعد قد يفضي للعثور
عليها حتى
الان تم اكتشاف اشارتين منفصلتين في الجزء
الشمالي من منطقه البحث المحدده الاشاره
الاولى استمرت لحوالي ساعتين وع
دقيقه المسؤولون يقولون ان هاتين
الاشارتين تتفقان مع ما تم ارساله من
مسجلات المعلومات بالطائره لكن الاخبار
السيئه هي ان تاكيد ذلك سيستغرق اياما
فيما تنفذ بطاريات الجهاز من الطاقه نحن
بالفعل متاخرون بيوم عن انتهاء المده
الافتراضيه ونحن نامل بان تستمر بالعمل
لفتره اطول قليلا طواقم البحث لا يمكنها
تعقب مصدر الاشارات فحسب فالامر اكثر
تعقيدا من
ذلك خلافا للهواء حيث يتنقل الصوت في خط
مستقيم الطاقه الصوتيه تتاثر بشكل كبير
بدرجه الحراره والضغط والملوحه في الماء
وهذا يؤدي الى تخفيف او حني الصوت الى 90
درجه في بعض الاحيان وفي حين ان موقع
الحطام هو الدليل النهائي لفهم ما حدث
للطائره ينظر المحققون في معلومات اخرى
للبحث عن اجوبه مسؤول رفيع بالحكومه
الماليزيه قال لسي ان ان الاحد ان الطائره
قد تكون حلقت حول المجال الجوي لاندونيسيا
ما يشير الى ان المسار قد تم تصميمه لتجنب
اكتشاف الرادارات
للطائره